Okay.
That should be good.
I open restream as well.
And then I'll switch the um
I'll switch the view over in a second.
Hello folks.
I've been out for a couple of days. We
had um
some rush order stuff, let's say, with
uh one of our clients that we had to
take care of.
And uh we're still kind of on the clock
in some sense.
Um
we have a lot of professional work to
get done.
The good news is some of it relates to
self-play.
I think I can say that much.
And um we already have a environment for
self-play that's pretty good for
research.
So, what I figured that we would do now
is I would just do some streaming for
you know, whatever amount of time makes
sense, and we will work on uh some of
the self-play research.
I will give a quick summary of what I've
been doing so far in a few minutes.
>> Okay.
So, um I guess so far what we should say
is RoboCode. Let's actually let's show
the environment off first of all.
I have it on the website still.
I think I have it on the website.
Yeah.
Hey Liberty. So, this is RoboCode. It's
like this tank battle and let's see, can
I take over for it? Yeah. So, it's this
tank battle and you can steer the tank
around, you can shoot bullets.
You have this like radar thing.
Uh but it's set up in kind of an
interesting way such that there actually
a lot of different strategies. Like it
doesn't look like there are, but there
actually a lot of interesting strategies
to this thing. And uh there are a ton of
different scripted models available that
people have come up with for this.
And uh this is what we're going to use
for our self-play.
There've been some improvements since
then. Let me uh
Hang on a second. Let me read this
first.
Okay, this is good.
And let me set up another experiment and
then I'll talk through this.
Um I have to I'm sort of in the loop of
um
running a bunch of experiments and they
take a while to run, so I can talk
through stuff I've done so far
once I have it running.
Yeah, we'll see if this does anything
and then if not I will I'll consider
otherwise. So um here's the deal with
the RoboCode. First of all, we have a
setup that lets us train at 100 million
steps per second.
An eight GPU setup. Um it turns out that
Puffer 4 is just really really fast
multi-GPU.
I sort of knew this, but then I kind of
forgot that I'd done all the engineering
to make that work. So,
yay, we have the ability to run
multi-billion step experiments very very
quickly.
Um
second thing is we have a historical
self-play setup.
Um and
I've been testing it on
Robocode.
And the game is clearly non-transitive.
Uh, meaning that you can take a scripted
bot, you can train against it, that'll
work. You can train self-play, that'll
work.
Uh, you can take the self-play bot and
evaluate it against the scripted bot.
And that will fail.
But if you evaluate a self-play trained
bot against a bot trained against the
scripted bot,
then that one will work.
So,
it's kind of non-transitive. There are a
bunch of different strategies. I need to
watch some of the policies for sure.
But self-play alone ain't doing it.
Likewise, historical self-play.
Historical self-play gets you um,
consistent performance against your past
policies.
But it still doesn't generalize well to
held-out policies at all.
Domain randomization helps a little bit,
doesn't solve the problem.
Doesn't solve the problem.
Um, and like several different
permutations of this already tried.
Okay?
So, what do we do from there? Well, I'm
going to try a couple things with
exploiter agents. That's what I'm doing
now.
Which is what happens if we train agents
to try to beat the current policy. Does
that get us interesting diversity and
robustness in the policy?
We're trying a few versions of this
next. And if this doesn't work, then
we'll see what the heck else we can do.
Um,
I've gone through some of the lit on
self-play.
And stuff is actually a fair bit lower
quality than I remembered.
I actually don't think a lot of the
techniques out there are particularly
well established
or particularly likely to work well.
I do think that self-play is probably
something that you can just force to
work if you randomize sufficiently.
Um but you're kind of relying on task
engineering.
The trick to it is you need to get
something that incentivizes enough
diversity in the
in the gameplay, so it's able to respond
to many different strategies, and that's
kind of tough.
Blah, blah, blah.
Um this is again sort of the same loop I
was doing before where
I am testing experiments with stupid
code X.
Um but it's mostly it's kind of just
calling puffer lip at this point.
There's very little code associated with
this.
Like all the work is sort of done in
puffer already, and this is just writing
like shitty analysis scripts over logs
and stuff that are all throwaway.
And then if we get something to work,
we'll do a uh proper implementation of
it.
Um but self-play is actually something
that we need need need to work.
And relatively soon.
And to be fair, it can be made to work
on individual tasks, but
we'd like it to be much more robust than
this.
>> 28 with 10 1 2 3 1 2 3
and billion steps.
We are attempting self-play things
today.
Oh, and yes, this is 106 million SPS.
That you're seeing that correctly.
Self-play agenda is
I mostly want to understand today
whether exploiter agents as a concept is
legitimate or not.
Is this something that actually [ __ ]
works?
This should be basically an ideal end
for it.
These will take a little bit of a while
though.
Cuz like let's see if I do
Oh, I think this is not um
Yeah, this is not training exploiters.
Well, that so far the historical stuff
is not working, Jess.
I still think the league thing
the full league thing from AlphaStar,
I'm actually still very skeptical of.
And I'm very skeptical of this, but
essentially I've just down weighted the
all of the evidence on all the different
approaches recently.
So, um
we're back to basically having no idea
what the [ __ ] potentially works and
knowing that we can get it to work on
any individual problem
but with domain specifics.
I'm trying to see if any of these
various methods
actually reduce the amount of domain
hacking.
I already did a little bit of DR on
RoboCode specifically.
>> So what this experiment is doing here,
this is training for 10 billion steps
total.
And every 1 billion steps it stops the
training exploiter agent for 5 billion
steps. So it's very slow.
But uh we're going to see if this works.
The FPS didn't change much.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out just um
it actually seems to me okay, so
historical alone is fine for stability.
Um you can actually get policies that
get consistently better over time with
just historical self-play.
Uh and that's like pretty cheap. It's a
little bit of engine, but it's pretty
cheap. That definitely works.
At least um yeah, that definitely works.
The thing that I'm less certain about
though, right, is the strategy coverage.
You know, how do you actually get the
bot to continue improving and continue
discovering lots of different
strategies?
Oh yeah, also I think a thing that you
might not have realized
um historical self-play scales amazingly
with more GPUs.
Because you just give every GPU a
different opponent.
So
like the oh no, how do we train against
eight different opponents at the same
time? You use eight different GPUs.
And that's basically free.
So that was one little change that I
added that helped a lot.
>> That'll go into self-play.
Well, it'll go into whatever version of
self-play ends up actually working,
Jess. We need something that works.
Cuz this [ __ ] decidedly does not work.
To give you an idea, okay, we can train
Let me get this correct.
We can train an agent versus a scripted
bot very easily, okay?
Um we can train
an agent in self-play that beats all of
its previous checkpoints.
We can train an agent against the agent
that we trained versus the scripted bot,
and it'll beat that.
But we can't take
we can't take the self-play agent and
beat the scripted bot directly.
So, it can beat the bot that was trained
against the scripted bot, but it can't
beat the scripted bot.
It's very weird.
That's what I've been banging my head
against.
Wait, were you doing this on RoboCode?
What were you using Like what were you
testing this with, Jess? Or did you have
this with chess?
Cuz if so, that's the first I've heard
of it.
And also tried it with chess. Okay.
Okay, so that makes sense then. So,
you can learn something that exploits
the scripted bot in a sense,
but it's actually a weaker overall
policy. That's interesting.
Well, we'll see how this goes then.
It's cool to know that that's a thing
though, right?
And the fact that we get the same result
on Robo code. I think Robo code is
actually a very nice end for this.
Yeah, yeah, convert.
We know Puffer is very fast.
The guy that built it must be really
smart or something like that. I don't
know.
Nice haircut. Thank you.
I was sick of feeling like a woolly
mammoth.
It's funny that this is like, "Oh, this
experiment is so annoying. Like, man,
Puffer is so slow when it has to train
for 60 billion steps."
I got to get my I will get myself a
shorter dev loop. We'll like to shorten
the experiments or something after this.
But I want to have like a couple high
confidence results first.
Yield some general Yeah, so that's the
point, Finn. Um
this is a much better way to make
progress on general self-play than doing
it directly on the client end, and I can
stream it.
Also, everybody, welcome Finn
officially. Finn has joined us for the
summer as an intern.
Already doing some cool drone work.
Also, yeah, Finn, let me know what you
need. Um like let me know what stuff you
need from from me. And also, like do not
feel that you need to stay up super late
because of the time zone thing. Like you
don't have any required hours or
whatever.
>> [laughter]
>> So, if you're tired, like go to sleep.
I know it's a little annoying with the
time change, but
You're complaining you have to wait a
day to get billions. I'm complaining
that I have to wait a minute to get
billions.
We actually can get 1 billion steps in
10 seconds now, or 11 seconds, I guess,
with this.
It's pretty ridiculous. This is 80% done
already.
It's already done 50 billion steps while
I've been talking.
I'm actually pretty confident now that
um
this is faster than the original Dota
training.
I'm pretty confident in that.
Like that we're now at the scale where
we can train small models
um on one node faster than
like the big scale-up experiments from
the labs.
Hello, welcome.
So, all we're looking for essentially
here, right? Is we're looking for
um consistently training exploiters that
beat the main policy, and then the main
policy learns to be robust to the
exploiter agents, and then we're looking
for held out perf.
Oh, yeah. I will say though, Jess, I
think that self-play aside, 4.0 is
pretty much good enough for most tasks
already.
I uh I really do not care about the GTA
series at all.
Self-play merged?
Uh I think so, yeah.
But, Kinvert, it's like
It is, but it's dev code. Like, I'm not
saying this is ready. I'm saying I'm
actively doing experiments on this.
Robocode is In my mind, Robocode is the
correct end to be doing this on.
Not enterprise yet. Fair enough.
Upper five bucks.
>> For GTA 6.
>> Oh, yeah. Also, Jess, there was a bug
with Robocode that was essentially
invalidating all of the historical
results on on Robocode.
So, I fixed that.
And it did get better.
It got to the point where now it's at
least it's improving over time versus
its past self,
but it's still not going to held out.
I'm literally just letting this thing
run evals cuz the
on our stupid eval like set like a set
up is bad.
Mentally, I'm kind of
I guess the research stuff is cool and
all, but mentally I really just want to
be done with five and I want to be on to
puffer six already.
I think that puffer six is basically
just going to be me taking the time this
project deserves to properly clean up
the code and make everything very clean
and usable and consistent. Um
yeah.
Uh we don't really have a point for AMD
kernels convert.
We probably will have to do a better CPU
mode.
I don't really I think this is kind of
meme.
But now the mean is not robust and then
it doesn't generalize. Okay.
Uh yeah, we have stuff on that and Finn
is actually um
Finn has work that will be
on that topic of what as well. He joined
us this Monday for internship.
>> Mixed results.
Actually, I think that's just fail
result there.
But then again, it's not winning against
the exploiters yet.
So I guess then the question is
can you win against 10 exploiter agents?
And still somehow be um
brittle.
That would likely in my mind just
invalidate the whole idea of exploiters.
The problem is at that point we start
running out of ideas, don't we?
All right, we've got 20 plus people
watching. Start sending me your um
start sending me references for your
best no [ __ ] self play
stuff.
Um
pure self play doesn't seem to work.
I think that it relies very heavily on
domain randomizing the task to get the
diversity into the data.
Um historical self-play gets you stable
perf versus your past checkpoint, but
it's still very brittle. And it's very
easy to exploit, and it's also not even
robust to um like simple scripted
opponents.
Exploiter agents is what we're testing
now. It's an incredibly inefficient
idea, and the results are mixed so far.
But this is what we need. We need better
ideas for self-play.
Um
a lot of the lit on this is just like
this really janky game theory heavy crap
that's tested on
Well, I say crap because it's tested on
very simple ends.
What is the main use case?
General self-play in puffer.
We want to have a um
we want to have some version of
self-play that lets us take
competitive tasks and train stable
policies on it.
It's not like we just have one game or
one task in mind, right? Like we need
this for client stuff, we need this for
research. There are a lot of ends that
are like a lot of problems that are very
nicely formulated as competitive
self-play tasks.
And um
you know, we have to approach things
very differently
if competitive self-play is not stable.
But I know it can be made to work.
It has plenty of history behind it.
Sweep ranges.
Lower LR seems to be better. So, Jess,
if you see um
if you see that your sweep is constantly
selecting the very very edge of one of
the uh the ranges, and it seems like you
can't get good policies without having
it be um
at the very end of the range, then the
range is too narrow.
Okay, it's just going to run it for me.
Fine.
So, this here is
this will take what? Probably
3 minutes? No. Hang on.
Uh 10 seconds per build. Yeah, four
three three to five minutes.
Um this is supposed to be 20 billion
steps
training against
the exploiter agents from before.
Hopefully
hopefully this is fine.
So, the question here, right, is we were
able to train
decent exploiter agents last time.
We trained lots of exploiter agents, but
then we weren't able to beat them. So,
if we just train against all these
exploiters directly, is it possible to
train against 10 different exploiters
and still have a brittle policy?
Are there public benchmarks?
For what? For self-play algorithms?
Uh yes, but they're very bad.
And the problem that we generally have
with Puffer in comparing to other works
directly
is uh we are able to train about 1,000
times faster than everybody else.
So,
we're not going to go and take
somebody's env where we have to spend
1,000 times the amount of uh compute
in order to get the same result. Or more
often times, it's like a slow benchmark
with a really simple environment.
It doesn't really make sense for us to
go and then you run our stuff on other
people's benchmarks because they're so
slow.
Uh if there's a benchmark that we really
like and we think is important, what we
do is we port the benchmark into Puffer
so that it's fast, and then we use it
for uh comparisons there.
I didn't really like any of the
self-play ones that I saw, though. I
think that the RoboCode env that we have
is a much, much better benchmark than
anything I've seen.
Oh yeah, what the heck is the title
here?
Reinforcement learning research with
Joseph. Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
This will be done in a couple of
minutes.
I should have run it myself, though.
Sort of silly.
Time limit instead of a steps budget?
Um, I mean, we basically do in the sense
that how did I choose 20 billion steps?
I chose 20 billion steps because it was
like
the longest I was willing to wait on
something.
And when we to when we compare
algorithms, we actually do compare based
on wall clock. We don't compare based on
steps.
That's actually built into our sweeps
algorithm. And to my knowledge, we're
the the only library that has our sweep
our sweep implementation set up that
way, which is one of the reasons we're
able to solve tasks so quickly.
Oh, I saw that. I think that I didn't
like this paper, man.
This is the recent one, right? This is
actually I think these are our
collaborators, right?
Oh, no, no, no. This is a different one.
I saw this. This one was super jank,
though, right?
This one was like super jank when I
looked at it. It's just a ton of math
formalism.
And
it's a ton of math formalism.
And it seems like
very oddly posed.
Like anything that's based on computing
an oracle
is kind of nuts.
It's like this theoretical framework for
unifying stuff.
I'm super sketched out though by the
DeepMind stuff in general. Hang on, let
me answer one thing.
It fins just sent over an reasonable
idea. Very good. Um
Yeah, so the reason I'm sketched out
with DeepMind stuff
is in my mind you had at the same time
OpenAI and DeepMind solving problems of
comparable difficulty.
And DeepMind used really fancy methods
and OpenAI used really simple methods.
So, I think that the methods are more of
a reflection of the uh
ideologies
of the researchers than of what's
actually required.
The thing that I am a little sketched
out on, which I think that both are
likely to be equally guilty of,
um
you know, the key problem is like if the
bot is missing something strategically,
right? Like it's missing some aspect of
the game that makes it brittle.
Uh in both cases, you have the
researchers sitting there watching their
agents playing the game constantly,
right? And they say, "Oh, that looks
wrong. Let's change it so that that gets
fixed."
So, I think that if I were to just even
use vanilla self-play with the RoboCode,
I think I could probably like pretty
easily come up with something that would
full solve it.
But I would have to be tweaking the env,
tweaking the end, tweaking the end.
So, I guess what I want to know is to
what extent on the algorithm side can we
get some level of robustness
versus
uh to what extent is it as soon as you
have to do self-play, like the strategic
diversity issue is just unsolved and you
have to do a bunch of manual work.
World models the guardrails for too long
to I think that's troll.
Yeah, I that's troll and that certainly
doesn't solve the uh that certainly
doesn't solve this either.
I can look up this one.
They didn't use human data at all on the
uh capture the flag one, did they?
This architecture was kind of
interesting.
Oh, yeah, this is the one that had the
cool web visualizer, right?
I mean, this is no more complex than
RoboCode, right?
It's a pretty simple task.
I mean, they can't
The thing that's annoying, right, is
they say self-play and they put it at
zero.
Um
What this basically means we didn't even
[ __ ] try with our baseline at all.
And we just went straight to doing the
fancy thing.
It's this.
We're doing one-v-one of this. It's a
tank battle game. You can shoot
projectiles, you can steer, you can
move. And uh you have like both a gun
and a radar that are independently
steerable. And the observations are set
up such that you can't see the bullets,
you can only see when they're fired. So,
there's like a lot of um heuristic
prediction into where you think your
opponent is shooting and where you
should dodge.
There are a bunch of different
strategies. You can try to ram into your
opponents, you can try to predict where
they're going and shoot there.
Um you can try to get close, you can try
to get farther away. Uh you can try to
just dodge a bunch of bullets because it
takes energy, which is the same as life,
in order to
in order to shoot.
You can shoot fast shots that are
weaker. You can shoot slower, bigger
shots.
This is a yetterburg.
All right.
I will say um
This is a stupidly complicated method
for only having played 450k games.
That's nothing.
They must have just gig it I think that
what happened with DeepMind here is they
just massively [ __ ] troll on their
engineering team.
Cuz there's no way that you need like
This is a tiny number of games. They
probably have this super fancy method
because they just don't have any data at
all.
450k games, they're like one or
two-minute games. That's nothing.
But we can literally train on this
amount We're probably doing more data
right here in our run than they have in
theirs.
I remember no noticing that they used
like tiny amount of data in their thing.
Okay, well, we're not going to be able
to find
Okay, so look, just self-play plus
reward shaping
We'll do that next, I suppose. We go
back to basics.
>> We can do population-based thingy
potentially. We'll see.
Oops.
Oops, my OBS.
This is from the partnership with
Cerebras. No.
Hopefully this gives us an actual result
finally.
I think we should decide based on this
result if it beats the exploiters well,
but it loses to the scripted bots.
I think we drop the whole approach.
At least for now.
I think that's like enough time invested
and we consider this unpromising.
Wait. So,
we beat all the exploiters
and we do terribly versus scripted.
What are you making so many hours for,
man?
We got any Oh, okay. Wait a second. What
is this?
You got to actually like get some of
these polished nice.
Need job so more projects.
I think you need like fully like
finished polished projects that can be
used for research or like applied or
whatever.
I've been All right. All right, I hear
you.
But you can't flood me with M's, man.
Like
We do need M's, but like
The lock on possibly actually.
We need M's that are especially
interesting or challenging versus what
we have in some way.
That's pretty damning, right?
That means the exploiter idea sucks.
>> So, I think that that is reasonable.
In my mind, they're just very brittle.
So, like these exploiter agents aren't
really
They're kind of just exploiting like
They're not exploiting like high-level
weaknesses as much as they're just like
very nitpick things that uh
you could very, very easily train
against.
Okay, whatever. So, that's fine.
What do we do from here?
Exploiters fail.
It's been long enough Anish.
That um people aren't just asking me
[ __ ] constantly.
What environment it's self-playing? It
is working on RoboCode, which I think is
a perfect environment for this. You can
look it up.
We have a port of it to see that's super
fast. We can train at 100 million SPS.
I'll wait.
Um
Ryan, I don't think that they do
anything.
From the recent experiment, it seems the
exploiters just don't [ __ ] do
anything.
Because if you could if you can train 10
exploiters and you're training it like
the way I did it is the policy trains
for a billion steps and this is a very
nice big experiment as well, right? Cuz
look, 100 mil SPS training. So, this is
a pretty like large-scale result as
well, I would say on a hard environment.
Um you can train for a billion steps,
then you train an exploiter for 5
billion steps from scratch and you
repeat that 10 times,
you get a good policy for 10 billion
steps.
You get 10 exploiters that did well
against the checkpoints,
but you have a policy that does well
against all the exploiters at the end.
Uh and that policy is crap against held
outs.
So,
and it's not even like meaningfully
better against held outs either than
just doing normal self-play.
Why not train on use cases in medicine?
Uh that is where we're eventually going.
That is actually my biggest goal for
Puffer is to get it into biological sim,
uh but I don't want to do it in a way
that's [ __ ] right? Like that is
actually some hardcore molecular
simulation development work
and I want reinforcement learning to be
a stable, consistent
um a stable, consistent branch of ML
essentially. I want our stuff to
actually work consistently and not feel
jank.
I think we're less than a year away from
that.
You train the final policy on self-play?
Yes, I did self-play plus exploiters.
Fine-tuning is played from base policy.
Yeah, I think that it's worth to
fine-tune though, Ryan, because the
point of exploiters, right? The point of
exploiters is that you want something
different from the main policy.
And you want it to just like look for
what is the easiest way in which you can
beat the specific main policy at the
moment. You're looking for shortcuts.
And that I think is better done from
scratch. So, yes, you could possibly
speed it up.
But I think this was like the cleanest
test I could have run. And keep in mind,
I didn't have much faith in this
approach from the start. I think this is
like a I gave it like a reasonable
chance. It's a absolutely god-awful
method from a a perspective of
computational efficiency anyways.
So, and I also I think that um, it is
very likely that in AlphaStar, they got
a lot of the data diversity from
bootstrapping human data up to diamond.
Also, we know that DeepMind uses way
over inflated methods anyways when
they're not required at all. So, I don't
think that the evidence behind that
method was particularly strong to begin
with.
The historical self-play on its own is
at least producing policies that
consistently improve over their past
checkpoints. And I think that the likely
the recipe for Dota and for um
emergent tool use was just like that.
So, you have agents that are
consistently improving over time plus a
manual loop of looking at the
environment, seeing what the agents are
missing, and screwing with reward
functions or uh domain randomization.
That's probably what happened.
Yeah, I remember. Hey, Muhammad.
Um
Exploiters learn real strategies. Only
ones against yourself play.
I mean, more to make you play or do real
strategies.
Yeah, but the point I suppose Ryan was
the Exploiters are that's the namesake,
right? They're meant to exploit. It's
not supposed to be a real strategy. It's
supposed to cheese. You're training
cheese agents.
Um
And the question, right, is does beating
a whole bunch of different cheese agents
does that actually let you have a robust
policy? And the answer is no. Like, if
you get different strategies that are
bad but are outside of your
distribution, you're it does not make
you robust to those.
This technique does not seem at the very
least, it's not something that you
sneeze in the direction of and it works.
Also, um if I may advertise for Puffer a
little bit for you here,
uh if you want to do your research at
100 million steps per second, there's
only one library that lets you do that.
So.
100 million steps per second training.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Exploiting an episode doesn't improve
policy, it chooses the best result.
Like an episode
Uh exploiter agents are just agents that
you're training against a fixed
checkpoint. So, the idea is because it's
training against another fixed policy,
it's just training to beat it in
whatever the easiest way possible is. It
doesn't have to know anything else other
than how to exploit this one policy.
How did you do this? How do you connect
multiple machines? Oh, isn't that that's
the funny part Liberty, we don't.
>> [laughter]
>> This is on one machine.
Eight GPUs, but one machine.
Puffer's just really, really fast.
So yeah, you want 1 million step per 100
million step per second training,
that'll be $4 to $5 per hour.
How do you see safety in Sim to real?
What methods work best?
Um
I mean, that's very, very problem
dependent.
Like there problems for which safety is
not even remotely a concern at all in
Sim to real.
And then there problems for which is a
very large concern, but then the concern
is not even in the Sim to real, it's in
the behavior in the Sim itself being
unsafe.
Like
that's too broad of a thing.
Safer self-driving.
Uh actually, there was just a very good
paper published on that.
Very, very good paper. In fact, if we
use any method for imitation whatsoever,
it'll be this one.
Obviously, agent will be very
exploitable without them. No, it won't.
That's not obvious, Ryan.
They didn't do it with Dota.
And Dota beat the top team in the world.
And then they ran it against um
they ran that agent against like uh
everybody for a weekend and the only
people that could find cheeses were like
top Elo players exploiting niche edge
conditions.
Like there was not a single group that I
saw of low or mid Elo players being able
to win under any circumstances.
I think this is more so like the oh
obviously it'll work it won't work
without this. That's a deep mindism.
No, no, no, but Ryan. Like
there were zero instances of lower mid
Elo players being able to even find an
exploit.
For the top Dota bot.
A few players were able to win with like
a max Elo stack of players.
It There were no like easy cheeses.
None.
And that's just from historical self
play.
Plus domain randomization and reward
shaping obviously.
I think of all of the results
in the field that is the strongest.
The hero pool.
The constraint No, that was That's not
true.
That's not true.
People need to actually read this paper.
This is the best paper in the field.
Okay, look how well this thing scales.
Okay, five heroes.
Look look at these curves, right? Five
heroes, 10 heroes, 17, 40, 80.
You see this?
So, the constraint was essentially on
compute. And this thing was scaling very
very well. Like you'd expect it to be
much harder to learn this many heroes.
It actually was scaling amazingly well.
It's just that by the standards of the
time and without the uh the level of
engineering that we have for RL
nowadays, this was already like $10
million or whatever to run.
There were some constraints, but very
few, and they kept removing them every
update. It was mostly stuff just being
hard to um
like literally hard to put in the action
space. By the time they did the game, it
was pretty much the full game. Like most
of the constraints were from early
versions, and they just kept
consistently removing them.
Mechanically hard.
Not playing them below diamond, but
they're exploitable in strategy space.
Um Dota is a lot less so that than
StarCraft, Ryan. Like
Dota's basically old man's League of
Legends.
League of Legends. Um
Okay, so it doesn't really learn
anything without reward shaping, it
seems.
It's too hard with 0 1 reward, it seems,
and current hypers.
Which makes sense looking at gamma and
such. Okay, I'd buy that.
Really hard to bring about variety. Yes.
I think it's the variety is the key
issue, and actually Dota's I actually
think that that's the reason that Dota
scales so well with many heroes.
Um
This like yes, you have to learn lots of
different mechanics.
But this scales way better than humans
do, right? Like
having people play 80 heroes, good
[ __ ] luck.
Um
I actually wonder what the Elo gap here
would be.
You know, like if you just put people on
if you have to have a pro player play
like one of 80 heroes if they have a
bigger gap than this.
Because I think that this is essentially
just giving you
more diversity in the training data.
Um so that Ryan, that seems to be true.
At least historical self-play on its own
doesn't. But they did so very well with
Dota.
So, I think it's the combination of the
game having diversity plus domain
randomization plus rewards or something.
But, the thing is the exploiter agents
also don't help cover the strategy space
from the last experiment. They seem to
just suck.
Uh no, Jess. I think that's troll.
That is fixed just by historical.
Obviously, I'll
>> historical star
>> Yeah, but I I really think that like oh,
this method works for DeepMind is a very
weak signal, Ryan. DeepMind was like
they love throwing fancy methods at [ __ ]
for no reason.
That's kind of their whole stick.
Like, I believe that their stuff works,
but I don't believe that it's necessary.
And like, the thing is it probably
doesn't work for the reason that they
say, either.
Non-transitive don't
No, the non-transitive strategy is that
matters a lot and in fact we have very
clear evidence that that is occurring in
RoboCode. Um, but like you just fix that
with historical self-play. That part is
fixed.
Yeah, but Ryan, if you beat all of your
past checkpoints, you've solved that,
right?
If you have no cycles whatsoever in your
training, if it's just monotonic
improvement, then you've solved that.
Think that works, yeah?
I agree.
>> Do
do
Does that prioritize it
weight by win rate? Uh I looked Spencer
said that didn't help very much.
And also
I looked at the Dota paper and the
distribution is basically flat if you
look at it anyways.
Also, isn't that something different as
well? Isn't fictitious different from
historical?
F S P
I'm never sure if there's a I was never
sure if there's a difference there.
Fictitious is a really stupid name,
though.
I'm not going to use that. Whoever came
up with like that was a dumb name.
This is the paper that I trust the most.
So let's just take a look at data
points, right?
So
emergent tool use works with normal
self-play, not even historical
self-play.
Dota works with historical self-play.
The DeepMind papers that are known for
using fancy-ass methods use fancy-ass
methods.
Okay, I knew I know the pri- I know
prioritized self-play, obviously.
The fictitious part I don't know about.
I know the prioritized historic, though.
Fine.
Yeah. So, Spencer, the latest is the
exploiters don't do anything. Um
learning 10 cheese strats doesn't
actually give you a robust policy.
And I'm suspecting, if anything, that
it's
likely I think all the magic is in the
rewards and the um
domain randomization.
Oh.
I was wondering why I had no spoons for
my soup. They put them with my pastry.
I suspect it's more likely that
the reward shaping that's used to get
you to play against a
scripted bot
is essentially just locking you into one
strategy.
KL divergence is a heuristic. I don't
see how.
How do you know what 10 X players are
learning to exploit?
And not learning something. So, you
don't know that they're are learning
something very similar, but if they are
learning something very similar then the
algorithm is bad anyways, right?
Also, training exploiters is like a
horrendously inefficient algorithm. I
was only testing it in case it was like,
oh yeah, this instantly just works.
Um, that's not suspicious Spencer
because I have self play off.
So, the frozen bank should be um
not used at all.
I also did confirm that you're getting
different results with um
with historical self play. I I fixed
that error.
I think it still just tries to load the
policy even if you have the damn thing
disabled.
I mean, I've been able to get policies
that basically monotonically improve
versus their past checkpoints. That part
of historical self play works.
Spencer, did you verify across the three
M's
by running like a big tournament with
all of the checkpoints or just by the
Elo metric in the logs? Because the Elo
going up metric doesn't actually mean
that it's improving.
I confirm that that metric can go up
even if you're getting worse against
past checkpoints.
Tourneys, okay, good.
So, we have we have a way to improve
over past policies.
That's good.
When I count Elo across all of them,
the later policies are better.
True skill is not better than Elo. I've
like that bit me very hard during my
PhD. I absolutely hate true skill as a
metric
because of the way it adjust variance.
It doesn't produce you a um
True skill does not produce for you a
reasonable like X point Elo difference
equals X skill difference thing.
It produces this really, really
unintuitive metric that's hard to
analyze.
Yeah, I did all that stuff convert. It
was annoying.
it kind of complicates it if you want to
use one of the fancier metrics.
Cuz you can't use them for
you can't use them for ranking.
You can kind of only use them for MMR.
I think what a lot of the games do is
they have a visible Elo.
And then they have an internal MMR that
affects how many points you get or lose
per game.
Because the thing is the internal MMR is
like completely
unintuitive.
Cuz like nobody wants to like
you know, load up their game of
OverWatch or whatever and see like, "Oh,
yeah, your true skill increased by .3"
or whatever. And then the next like 100
games later it's only increasing or
moving by like .05 per game.
And it's like it's not the case that a
difference of X points is good or bad.
But you need the visible Elo because the
internal Elo makes no goddamn sense.
It doesn't matter if it's more correct
if it's meaningless. Like
if I say, "Hey, there's a two-point true
skill difference between these two
players, you have no idea what that
means.
Right? If I tell you there's a 200 Elo
difference between these two players,
you know, okay, this one wins three out
of four games.
You can use those methods internally,
but you still end up needing a visible
Elo.
This might be too sparse.
I'm just seeing if we can get some
hypers in a few minutes that um
will beat the scripted bot
without reward shaping.
Cuz I'm kind of what I think is
happening is we're just reward shaping
into a really aggressive dumb policy.
And actually, will this finish in a
reasonable amount of time?
Why don't we take a moment to just go
over like the possibilities here?
We'll go over the possibilities real
quick.
And then I'll take like um
a few minute break while I uh I go get
my vitamins or whatever and then this
runs for a little longer. So,
we've done pure self-play.
It can work, but it is unstable.
And for complex games where like A beats
B, well, non-transitive games, we should
say, where A beats B, B beats C does not
mean that A beats C.
That's non-transitive.
Um
you need something to smooth it so that
you don't forget how to play against
previous policies.
Uh we do find, and I think we have very
conclusive results, that historical
self-play fixes this.
So,
maybe you can very extensively tune
normal self-play.
But in this sense, historical self-play
seems to be a very good algorithm.
Now, the problem
is that improving
against yourself
uh doesn't actually mean that at any
reasonable rate
you are learning to be better against
even relatively easy held-out opponents.
That is the major problem we've seen
thus far.
Now, I will say
it doesn't look like this has been
a massive issue
in either of the top trustworthy, I
would say, papers that I'm referencing
here.
Um
it's possible that
the authors of both hide and seek and
Dota were just kind of like looking at
the policy, seeing what it was doing,
tweaking the reward function, tweaking
the end of and doing that on loop until
it worked.
I would think it's very likely though
that we are somehow locking the policy
into one very specific way of playing
the game via the hypers and the reward
function.
So, I think the first order of business
is to see if we can get something more
generic that doesn't use a super
engineered reward function.
Maybe just uses like win the game or
whatever.
Um
I think the reward conditioning idea is
pretty solid of like training different
policies on different reward functions
and seeing if putting those in a
population gets you a robust policy.
I think that's pretty likely.
Obviously, we know that if we allow
ourselves to train against the scripted
policies, we win.
How do we evaluate what should go into
the pool then?
the pool?
There's the populace base training thing
that's kind of trolley.
Repeat the question. It's more of a
musing than it is a question, Jess.
So, I mean the issue that we're having
right is lack of diversity in behavior
in self-play.
I'd already did try sweeping versus bot
uh one. I don't know if that sweep was
very well set up though.
I think maybe we just what we do today
is we play around a little bit. We see
if we can get a
uh if we can get a reasonable set of a
reasonable policy with rewards that beat
that beat um
bot one
without shaping.
Or at least do decently. We run
self-play using those hypers.
We run some evals on that.
And then we probably just want to go
port a bunch of additional bots for
RoboCode and build a robust eval.
I think that's going to be it. We build
like a robust eval. We have like a nice
held out set of RoboCode opponents then.
And uh we basically just sweep self-play
where the
entire training is historical self-play,
but the eval is versus
uh versus these bots.
That's probably the most reasonable
thing
It's a little annoying though to sweep
because um
self-play historical self-play in
particular is much more efficient on
multiple GPUs than it is on one.
Like historical self-play on one GPU
kind of sucks.
Cuz you have a different opponent on
each GPU, so you get much more diversity
in the data.
It's a nice trick.
Oh.
Hey guys, there you go. Um after a
couple of minutes already, we have a
If this is to be trusted, we have a
perf of 49%.
So it looks like
this 5 billion steps.
Uh okay. So I mean it looks like we're
we are actually going to be able to find
something reasonable here.
Python may feed eval into observe to
navigate sweeps.
Well, yeah, we can do that, Jess, but we
would like once we refactor like once we
have uh puffer cleaned up, we'll just be
able to do that end-to-end in CUDA-C.
Okay.
Um yeah, I think what I'm going to do is
I'm going to let the sweep continue for
a few minutes. I'm going to go grab my
vitamins
and I'll walk around for a couple.
And uh hopefully we'll have a decent
enough config in a few minutes by the
time I'm back.
Uh we have quite a few people watching
actually at the moment. So uh thank you
all. I'm going to leave the stream up
and I'm going to be back in just a few
minutes. But if you are new around here,
I stream pretty much all of my dev.
And uh if you want to help us out for
absolutely free, puffer.ai, star the
GitHub.
It's 6K stars. It really helps us out a
lot.
You can join on Discord to get involved.
You can also follow me on X for more RL
content.
Um
I'll leave the env up actually
on the screen. Cuz this is this is the
task that we're using for training.
Obviously, this is a crappy policy.
I'll be right back.
Is this the default? I think this is the
default, right?
Does it just run the default for five
bill steps or whatever?
Which we know actually does not produce
good policies, huh?
The problem is these are janky hypers.
Okay, I mean we have stuff we can do in
the meantime.
Experience replay stratified sampling
over
Uh R4.0
replay is
uh it's advantage-based sampling of the
trajectory segments collected over a
single epoch.
Okay.
Um
Radiant descendant targeting surfing.
Huh.
We basically want We want like something
as simple as circular targeting.
Um, okay, grabbing the random jar file
for this. Sure.
I don't know why it's doing this, but
cool.
There's wave surfing, there's circular
targeting.
There's a whole bunch of basic ass
techniques.
Okay, here it is. It's just grabbing a
bunch of things.
That's fine.
I'm basically what I want to do is just
get Codex to port a bunch of the uh
a bunch of random ones.
Get like
I don't know, somewhere between five and
10 different bots to eval against.
More than the three that we have.
And they have like different levels of
difficulty to them.
So, some of them are open, some of them
are not.
Okay, so it's they've just all come up
with a bunch of heuristic methods,
right?
One for shooting.
What does that do for you, Liberty?
Like, why?
You still here?
Mhm.
We also
Lot of heuristics.
>> I wonder if we can run these directly.
We probably can't.
We don't have Java. Yeah, that sounds
bad. Let's do um
Easier to find out which versions in the
pool are better.
Not particularly and they're also kind
of joint.
Yeah, no, we have source for most of
them.
Um well, it can be like like jar it can
contain source, it cannot contain
source.
>> work and then create new Ms or use
existing Ms to develop algorithms.
>> Or both? And we do both. I mean Puffer's
kind of a comprehensive effort for um
a lot of the problems in the field at
the moment. So
we do algorithm dev on Puffer using
high-confidence environments that we've
built or ported.
And then we also, you know, we take
whatever the current version of our
algorithm is and then we try to build
new environments to solve specific
problems that we care about.
Yeah, I think this will be the
reasonable thing. So we get a larger
eval set.
Probably this thing makes a massive
mess, but as long as it doesn't screw
with uh
our core code, we don't really care.
As long as it doesn't screw with the
core envs at least.
We end up with big eval set. Any of the
ones that don't work or are super slow,
we just trash.
Um
there's they uh should be There's a lot
of old really legacy Java for this.
So there should be good reference. And
then I also I know of a couple basic
bots that we should probably include as
well.
>> Ocean, the multi-buffer is my Python
bindings.
Like we you have that in um
If you look at the puffer for
like puffer was it pytorch puffer or
whatever that pie.
Uh we use our own vectorization, but
with torch models.
I have no idea whether or not I will
bother keeping that in like puffer five
or six, but for now it's there.
It's just getting to be increasingly the
case that like oh, what if I want to do
it with torch? Well,
you're kind of trolling cuz it's super
slow.
Wait, so just randomly a couple people
submitted new bots?
To use puffer in production depends on
what you're trying to do.
I mean, you can train our bots and then
deploy them however you'd like.
Um
typically it's going to be if you have a
slow env
uh and you're kind of trying to do some
RL with it, you write a fast env and
then you train on that.
We also offer simulation engineering
professionally.
It's actually the main thing that we the
main thing that Puffer the company does
is uh
we help other companies build very
high-performance
simulators for their problems that are
compatible with Puffer. Obviously, you
can do it yourself as well.
Losing Puffer adapter in the future.
Well, it is and it isn't Puffer.
Like it gets to a point where it's like
cool, you can train in torch at like a
million steps per second or whatever.
But now Puffer trains at 20 million
steps per second, right?
So you almost like you get the a
completely wrong impression of what
Puffer can do if you're training that
slowly.
Like you're you're literally working in
a different field.
Um
every time you like go up an order of
magnitude in perf.
Especially with the new algorithms, like
the new algorithms that actually require
custom kernels to be done stable
and efficiently.
I will say that um
when eventually we get like a native
like end-to-end CUDA C version of Puffer
with no Python,
it will be quite simple.
I think arguably much simpler than the
Python is now.
It would probably be a mistake for us to
release Puffer ever with like no Python
binding
or whatever, but we'll probably end up
releasing a version where you can just
run end-to-end without Python and you
don't require Python for setup at all.
Just write the envs and the algos and
well, we have
Um yeah, the ends you definitely want
them C.
And then we have our algorithm. Our
algorithm's already state of the art for
the type of RL that we do. So, you can
use that.
And then on the research side, yeah, we
pretty much just extend the current
stuff.
Um keep in mind that most things that
you'd want to do end up just being like
very basic C.
Um
the exception being I suppose model
development.
You can prototype models in torch for
sure. That's fine.
Uh I will say though that if you're
thinking about what models are good and
efficient and you're only thinking about
them in terms of torch, you're going to
get the wrong answer.
Like for um
for example,
the model that we have in Puffer 4 that
is state of the art that like
solved a a bajillion different problems
that we couldn't solve before,
that uh that architecture is not
possible to implement efficiently in
torch.
Like literally torch is so bad, it just
it restricts the types of methods you
can even use efficiently
in a way that your hardware does not.
So, that's kind of one of the reasons
why we've gone lower and lower level.
Um
you literally prevent yourself from
considering a demonstrably useful set of
architectures and algorithms because the
things that can be made fast in torch
are a small subset of the things that
can be made fast on your GPU in general.
Uh we're running more of these, but just
none of them are outperforming yet, I
suppose.
I'm just basically letting this thing
try to port some agents or whatever.
Um
I figure I can do this like this can do
this while we run some experiments and
then we're going to go back to self
play.
Uh it I mean it is and it isn't pepper
like
the vast majority of papers I see in RL
end it being wrong
like straight wrong useless
because they run
very inefficient code on very easy
problems and then they they attempt to
draw conclusions from that.
Like you can't run like you can't just
go run a really fancy algorithm on a
really easy problem for 10 million steps
with horribly on optimal hyper
parameters on both your method and the
baseline and expect to draw any
reasonable conclusions.
Did your work not include way more CUDA?
It's CUDA C. There is CUDA.
actual models
Uh
check this out.
We're technically compiling the whole
thing as CUDA.
Um this includes the CPU launch code and
all the algorithm stuff that's more or
less just C, but the kernels are also
just sitting right in here.
And the uh the architecture that we have
is all custom kernels. But the thing is
because we don't have any sort of
attention based stuff in our
architecture
uh the kernels don't actually include
matmuls. So there's some complexity to
them, but they're much much much simpler
than they would be if they had to
include matmuls in them. Like we can
basically just call CuBLAS matmul. And
then it's all of the activations and the
loss and all the other sort of
intermediate plumbing that needs
kernels.
It's probably like 95%
of them.
>> Puffer.
>> Self-play like AlphaGo. Versions of
self-play are used in like AlphaGo,
OpenAI Five, AlphaStar, hide and seek,
emergent tool use, capture the flag, all
the big works from 2019-ish era
RL were self-play.
And there were a lot of confusing um
There were a lot of confounding
variables around what version of
self-play you actually need that works
and is simple.
That's what we're attempting to figure
out now. We're using RoboCode, which is
this 1v1 tank battle environment, as a
benchmark.
We're running large-scale experiments
like 20 billion steps of training
because Puffer is very fast.
And we are attempting to figure out how
we can get
agents trained just with historical
self-play or whatever version of
self-play we end up using to generalize
to a bunch of held out policies. So
we're going to train versus itself and
then see if we can beat a whole bunch of
scripted agents that are being well
attempting to be automatically ported
over from Java because there's no way in
hell you're going to make me manually
port
20-year-old Java code to C.
>> But while I'm doing while this is
happening here, right?
We are running some experiments on the
sweep.
I'm hoping we get some better hypers out
of this. We will see.
Um but otherwise this will just be
whatever garbage code.
Um system I do I definitely do things
differently because this exists.
I definitely do that.
I try not to like
This stuff you see on the side here, I
try very, very hard not to let this
screw up my main code base
because this always, always writes
unusable garbage code.
And if I just kind of let this add stuff
to popper and add stuff to popper, the
whole project would very quickly become
worthless.
So the version of this that I'm doing at
the moment is like
I get to try out crazy ideas much more
quickly
with not perfect confidence, right? Cuz
sometimes this just implements stuff
wrong or whatever.
But a positive result is usually good.
So if I try a crazy idea with Codex and
I get a experiment with popper that
works, then I dig into it and then if it
works if it actually ends up holding up,
then I will manually write uh rewrite a
version of it that actually can go into
the popper code base proper.
So it lets me run a bunch of like medium
confidence-ish experiments
pretty quickly.
Uh it's definitely not as good as me
taking the time to do it by hand.
Like it makes a lot of really dumb
mistakes.
But it does let me go through a lot of
different ideas quickly with
good enough confidence most of the time,
I would say.
I will say that this is a completely
boring. Like I absolutely hate working
this way. So uh I basically get no
enjoyment whatsoever out of my job
whenever I'm working this way.
And I end up taking a lot of time off
because how much this sucks. Like I
really really really would like to just
be
uh writing like manually editing
our like our core code base at the
moment and fixing little things,
improving Puffer in very small ways.
Like that's infinitely more satisfying
to me
than whatever the heck this is.
But
you know, unfortunately, if uh if I have
to have a miserable work day in order
for progress to be made on Puffer, then
I just have to have a miserable work
day.
How are most of the RL papers wrong?
Um
so most RL papers are trivially wrong.
If you just go to your typical
conference
what you will do is you will go and see
a bunch of very simple exper- like very
simple environments where they're
training for 10 million steps.
And uh they do 20% better than the
baseline and they've not hyperparameter
tuned the baseline.
And they've spent like 3 months tuning
their method.
That is trivially wrong because if you
do any hyperparameter sweep work
whatsoever in Puffer you know that
there's much more than a margin of 20%
uh just in the hyperparameters alone.
Much much more.
And now I missed a bunch of questions
here.
Uh
computer vision torch only PhD student.
So yeah, that's very common for um
researchers to not be able to get deep
enough into eng- I will say that the
stack that we have here matters a lot
more because of the model sizes in RL.
So torch is relatively much more more
for models in the hundreds plus millions
of parameters, but when you're down to
like single-digit million parameters or
lower,
um you really need the custom stack.
RL Jeppa, no.
JavaScript code is like typically used
in the game enemy game AI for eval.
Yeah, so the way that this game works,
um this was a programming game that was
used like 20 years ago. Um
Actually, when I first learned to
program, this was one of the things I
was shown.
The code base for the original Robocode
game is some of the worst thing it's
some of the worst code you'll ever see,
and it's basically taught a generation
of programmers how to write terrible
code,
but uh
the game itself is pretty cool, and
there are a whole bunch of different
agents out there or scripted bots
that have a bunch of different
strategies. It's really old bad Java
code, but I figured that since we have
Robocode ported to C now,
we can probably get Codex to just port a
bunch of these
bots, cuz I care about the quality of
the environment code, but I don't really
care so much about the quality of random
eval bots.
Puffer main is AI gen.
Like actual AI gen, almost none of it.
I spent like months painstaking going
through by hand
and um fixing. We had a bunch of PRs
that were also like people doing kernel
searching crap.
I went through a lot of that as well.
Um, I think even like the little bits
that are still kind of like um, chunks
of this kernel, chunks of that kernel or
whatever, I still need to go through
that more of that by hand.
But I do mean it when I say that like
if I were to just take like the puffer
five code for instance, which is
um,
me using AI for experiments and if I
were to just commit that as main code,
you basically just destroy the project.
Um,
there's essentially no point in having
all of this if the code base is crap.
Like you actually like the whole point
of puffer is you understand exactly
everything about what's going on.
It's an amazing code base for research.
Sure, you know, it's 5,000 lines of CUDA
instead of 2,000 lines of torch, but
what you don't have is 3.3 million lines
of unreadable garbage torch source.
So,
the perf versus simplicity trade-off is
a real thing.
Um,
but I think that I think we're going to
be able to get like
probably puffer five
5 to 7,000 lines of code for the source
with all the new algorithm stuff that I
need to be in there.
All the goodie bells.
And quite clean.
What am I doing?
Wait, not do 3 hours of real coding.
It's getting embarrassing.
Uh, you just you need a project from
scratch to work on. See, the thing is
like
the problem the big problem with these
with AI code is it's so dog [ __ ] that
like it's normal to not be able to edit
AI gen code. Like they just output such
complete garbage.
Um
like that's normal. You should be able
to write stuff from scratch though.
Like I can still write stuff from
scratch and I way way way prefer that
like
I would like nothing more right now than
to just be able to go build an end from
scratch or build like a new thing for
puffer from scratch or whatever. Um
but you know, unfortunately for the
research side work at the moment, this
is relatively more time efficient.
And this still does not like keep in
mind this does not end up polluting the
code base at all because
we're not actually merging any AI gen
crap
right into the main code base.
This is all experiments for figuring out
what the algorithm should be.
And then once we know what the algorithm
should be, I will write a clean version
of it.
This is like here this is me trying to
answer questions like, you know, is
normal self play stable?
Um do you get monotonically
increasing performance over checkpoints
with normal self play? No. How about
with historical self play? Yes. Okay.
Now if you evaluate both of those versus
these specific scripted bots, does it
transfer and is robust? No. Okay, does
robustness increase as you train for
longer? No, it's completely
decorrelated. Okay, what about this
other question? Right? And it's just me
like iteratively asking questions like
this.
Um
that's pretty much what I'm doing.
that we have not found any better
configs yet.
Okay, so RLVR is
like irrelevant. That's language
modeling shenanigans.
We always have verifiable rewards in
normal RL and we have much stronger
algorithms.
Um
Torch has very fundamental differences
that really for any small model work,
though um you know, particularly with
the env the loop
uh Torch just has a huge amount of
overhead such that it is very, very
inefficient for models below a certain
size and the vast majority of models
that you use in RL are below that size.
Um
the whole rest of the RL stack that is
built around Torch external to Puffer is
essentially you have to throw it all
away. There's not a single aspect of the
historical RL stack that was done
efficiently which is why we over time
have rewritten the whole thing.
Um you need kernel code for everything
with Puffer
but also the kernels need to all be
fused in CUDA graph. So Torch just has a
million different kernels with a bunch
of overhead between them. It doesn't
really fuse stuff reasonably.
Um
the Torch compile that's supposed to
reduce overhead doesn't actually work at
all for small models no matter what you
do with it and it's super slow.
The kernel code is not code gen, it's
handwritten
by both myself and contributors.
Uh it's not particularly complicated
kernel kernel code for most cases
because
you don't actually need to fuse stuff
with the matmuls that badly. It's mostly
you just need to fuse a ton of
activation and sequence wise functions.
And you need to be very careful about
CUDA graphing stuff. Um
you also need to be very careful with
how you manage memory. All the memory in
Puffer is fully static. Everything is
fully deterministic and fully
reproducible, which is really nice. Lots
of other things.
Uh so yeah, custom parameterized
kernels. Yeah, so all our all of our
kernels are variable shape and they're
still faster than torches whatever torch
is doing, which I mean, like that should
be embarrassing for torch, but what are
you going to do?
Huh.
That's cool.
What programming languages? I mean, the
whole RL stack was in Python.
At some point I started doing like
Cython extensions.
And then eventually I realized that that
was dumb, so I just went to C.
There really weren't any other
reasonable considerations.
I also like I had to deal with the
Python C API for a while. That was
annoying.
I'm definitely most happy with just
these C portions of our code.
I'm basically always down to just jam
some C.
But this seems like it's fine.
These are probably slowish, but they're
probably okay.
The question is what do we do? Do we
eval versus these directly?
Do we hope that this is going to give us
some other results eventually?
Yeah, you definitely don't want to be
using Julia for this. That's troll.
You definitely want C native speed.
And C++ mostly just gives everybody ways
to screw up our nice code base.
Uh it really doesn't add that much.
There is like almost nothing I can think
of that I want from C++.
And if you do want C++ since
everything's compiled as CUDA, you do
have it right there.
But uh you know, we just do everything
CUDA C as closely as we can
inside of um
inside of that compile unit.
It's funny how transitive that like
non-transitive that is.
That's good no way that you just
implement some bots and that actually
you already get these like crazy
non-transitive things.
I'm kind of surprised that we haven't
found anything for this that's better
on uh on perf.
Cuz I know for a fact that this set of
parameters is not going to do much for
us with self-play.
We definitely don't want to just be
guessing hypers either.
This is also just not a good way to fit
hypers at all, is it?
>> It's difficult to say, right? Because
like
I don't know how much information I
should assume about the script today. If
I were trying to solve this in a setting
where I don't have a bunch of scripted
agents, it gets harder, doesn't it?
Do you see the problem I have here,
guys? Like
I It's not like how do we solve
RoboCode, right?
Um I have many, many avenues available
to me to solve RoboCode.
The general issue though is that we want
a robust and stable self-play method.
Um ability to evaluate the quality of a
policy
with self-play
because
you can't really
you don't have a score cuz it's relative
to yourself.
You can evaluate it against your
previous checkpoints, but that doesn't
actually tell you how good it is against
any other model.
Even if you do like held out evals
against another model, that doesn't tell
you how good it is overall because games
can be highly non-transitive. And in
fact, here's a very simple game that's
demonstrably highly non-transitive.
to evaluate this?
Now look, with RoboCode specifically, I
can get a lot of different scripted bots
and say, "Hey, if it beats all the
scripted bots, that's probably a good
thing."
But this is kind of a unique scenario
where I do have a bunch of different
scripted bots available to me.
And if I'm going to rely on being able
to evaluate a bunch of different
scripted bots, say during a sweep,
that's also not good.
subskill game. Yeah, but how the heck do
you do that?
Let me make sure I'm not running out of
credits on Vast.
I am running out of credits on Vast. Let
me fix that real quick.
Machine is less than five bucks an hour,
which is not bad.
I don't even want to try training
against these cuz they're slow, right?
Also, they're kind of tough.
Like self-play does give you a very nice
ability to bootstrap.
>> I could somehow do it as a property of
the sweep.
That's kind of getting to like
population-based training type stuff,
isn't it?
Could we do something
with a our sweep algorithm is better?
Can we do something
about like which policies get saved or
something like that?
Like we allocate one of the GPUs to just
run matches.
I mean, how do we know which policies
are different?
Have you ran into Philip?
That's fun.
Yeah, in a year I think in about a year
or so it's like you're really going to
see the stuff with Puffer because
so right now
we're not kind of we're really not doing
a bunch of flashy demos. We have a few
but a lot of the stuff is kind of
mundane looking research.
Um
because we know that the mundane tasks
map to the actual difficult parts of the
the problems that we actually care
about.
And they're faster to iterate on.
So I do expect that in like less than a
year it's all of a sudden they're going
to be a bunch of flashy demos
and uh a lot of people on the outside
are going to say what on earth, you
know, where'd all this progress come
from? But in fact the progress was quite
consistent. It's just that we were doing
real work and not just farming demos.
So
I think Philip sees some of that as
well. Um
so I think it's likewise I think even
he'll be surprised by some of the stuff
in a year or so.
Numbers. Yeah, the numbers are very like
like the fact that
having RL that can solve big mazes
without gaming them in any way like that
is a harder eval task than
pretty much anything else out there
that's used in any real research.
Um
Sokoban as well, amazing task, but do
you reward shape it or not? That makes a
huge difference.
So there are like all these very key
little details
that very very few people appreciate,
but it's fine. We don't have to care,
right? Like I no longer have to publish.
I only have to care. Well, obviously we
keep our clients happy, but outside of
that I only have to care about progress.
Like real progress in the field.
And then um if it takes a couple of
years before we have things to show that
people understand, that's fine.
That sounds just too good to be true.
Yeah, we do kind of have that problem
cuz most things in uh AI nowadays are
just [ __ ]
So, this is not [ __ ] You can go
download it and try it. Um it's
genuinely just a soda policy, soda hyper
parameter sweep, soda implementation,
soda out like everything.
And each one of those little components
has been months of like very, very hard
work.
Um
>> [sighs]
>> and a lot, a lot of evaluation.
I still don't know what to do with this
freaking
Like you need to just be able to
compare.
Like you need a real Elo number.
What changes are you trying to make to
self-play? I'm trying to make the
changes in which it works.
Limiting. I already have that liberty.
We have that under domain randomization.
That helps, but it's not enough on its
own.
And like to be fair, I could probably
solve a lot of individual problems by
going very far down that route.
But that's not really the core
question at the moment.
If you're just training against
checkpoints, hang on. If the pool is all
of the checkpoints from a sweep,
that should give you a lot of opponent
diversity.
I It's got to be something here though
with like
training against all the other agents
from a sweep, right?
But then how do you separately The sweep
is supposed to find the good
hyper-parameters, right?
Uh if why not hire hire a couple of
researchers?
So, I mean Spencer's now working on this
with me.
Um he did the original historical
self-play implementation on this that
I'm building on. He's working on other
client stuff.
And we just had Finn join us
uh on Monday. He's here for the summer
as an intern.
Um
we could try to scale it faster,
but if I tried to hire a bunch of
people, I'd have to take VC funding.
And uh it's essentially
the strings attached to VC funding are
and the constraints that that place on
what we can do
make it not worth it.
And it's easier for us to just grow
slowly and to be, you know, consistently
profitable
and uh
not to have anybody else essentially
setting our research agenda.
And so far it's been tremendously
effective, right?
I also the types of problems I'm
solving, there really is not a single
person in the world who I would say, "Oh
yeah, if I just had this person, they'd
solve it immediately."
What do I need to do to join? You just
contribute to the open source stuff,
man.
I mean, that's basically what Finn did.
He um
Finn pretty much just like sent us the
best PR we've ever received and and
asked for an internship, and I was like,
"Okay."
We don't have a physical office. I don't
see the point in doing that.
I myself don't like being in the same
place all year, either. One of the nice
perks of doing a
your own thing is you can kind of work
from wherever, so
I kind of move around every every few
months. I just need a change of scenery.
I think playing against the checkpoints
from a sweep
are you work alone or with co- I mean,
it's a big open source project. You can
literally join right now. Just
discord.gg/puffer
and start slinging code our way.
Thought we already did that. No.
We did the exploiter agent thing.
Um
we did historical self-play.
We have not tried sampling, like
treating the sweep itself as the thing.
Well, it's annoying in a sense, Jess,
cuz you're mixing two things, right?
Like trying to find good hyper
parameters.
And um
building out the set of opponents.
It also would mean that the experiment's
getting incredibly expensive very
quickly, right?
Because now you have to do a full sweep
to test anything.
So I guess you can keep the same frozen
set of opponents.
I would assume we'd have a better
solution. Yeah, there is not a better
solution that I see.
I mean, this does seem very inefficient
in a sense, though.
Uh the difficulty arch The problem we
have is not like can we learn
of against a fixed opponent. The problem
is getting diversity into the policy.
So we can crush basically any fixed
thing that we train against
very easily.
DeepMind does what? The annoying
population-based training stuff, right?
Also, why is this so difficult?
I guess it is genuinely possible that
RoboCode is actually a pretty tough
task.
Very non-transitive. It's probably this
is a pretty tough task for self-play.
Okay, that's at least nice, right? Like
it's not like we're having a tough time
on an easy task.
Um
We haven't tried it with an easy task,
Jess.
But the thing is any task that doesn't
have any sort of strategic diversity in
it, this will just solve.
Anything where it's like, yeah, there's
one solution or whatever, one reasonable
solution, this will just solve it.
We don't really want an easier task.
Like this is
I think this is ideal.
For self play from chess.
Well, Arch, this is um
this is not a turn-based game. So, other
than that, no. But
that's the key distinction. This is not
turn-based.
That is likely, isn't it?
You get different policies.
Doing this game engine RL hybrid in a
rust.
RL in the engine, currently using this
library called burn.
They're only comparable to torch in
speed.
M's in puffer.
Only on PPO. It's not only PPO. Uh we
have some very major algorithmic
upgrades to PPO.
Um we tried some stuff in search-based
methods. It's genuine It's generally not
the case that just search is better.
Search definitely lets you spend a bunch
of compute.
Uh it's unclear when it's unclear that
that is
often or you know
a reasonable chunk of the time even a
better thing to do.
I will say our baseline learning method
is ludicrously strong.
Like Puffer 4's learning method is so
strong that we actually have a tough
time coming up with
tasks that can't solve for Puffer 5.
Like well-posed problems that are fast
we typically just crush.
We can train a goddamn 100 million steps
a second, okay?
We should be able to afford
We should be able to make an entire
sweep fast.
I think we can make an entire sweep
fast.
How many experiments could I reasonably
run? Like 100?
But the thing is if I can get
I can genuinely do entire population
plus sweep if I can define it cleanly.
We just have one worker that's just
updating all the ELOs.
We have seven workers running
experiments.
Does that do it?
Entire I mean that we can do
we can genuinely do 100 experiments
um like we can do 100 x 100 mil
very quickly.
If that's what it takes to get us
like the training diversity.
>> How would that work for longer time
ranges?
No idea, Jess.
Let me go try Let me go check this
thing.
Man, this could just be such a big nerd
snipe is the problem.
>> It's annoying in a sense that this is
basically just exploration.
Yeah, this is basically just exploration
coming back to bite us and just
happening to bite us extra hard because
it's multi-agent competitive, right?
Hang on.
Let's assume that we have a sweep with a
held out evaluation, okay?
We Elo ranked those.
We throw out the crap ones.
Yeah, this thing [ __ ] sucked. So,
that didn't work at all.
Sweeping versus this did not help.
If I do num agents, num bots,
one,
you got to knock it totally lost in the
lost in this oss here.
This thing requires a held out
evaluation, but I think that you kind of
need some sort of held out.
You can always just make it like
whatever the best bot you have so far
is.
I'm going to enjoy this more than the
5-0.
Well, I enjoy thinking about stuff. I
hate like type [ __ ] into Codex, wait,
type [ __ ] into Codex, wait.
Okay, this is learning.
I'd rather it not take a a billion
steps.
I really would rather this not take a
billion steps to [ __ ] train.
>> Is there a good way to deal with
transitive policies? Historical
self-play
solves um solves transitive like
strategy cycles.
They're like dealing with transitive is
not the problem. The problem is just
finding all the strategies to train
against.
Training against everything is
sufficient.
Okay, there you go. This solves in 100
mil.
And this has annealing off as well.
So, we can just solve.
75.
Okay, that is a policy.
two
zero
Wait, 90/10 loss uh split between
accumulative loss function
validation loss is able to isolate
plateaus much faster independent of
I don't know what you mean there.
I do not know what you mean there.
That should help.
Yeah, I'm not following that.
This is like self-play RL setup, yeah?
>> Surveillance self-play.
I didn't somebody link that earlier?
Is it the
>> [sighs]
>> I forget if it was a Tsinghua or
different Chinese university, but like
it was this very weird theoretical
framework.
I've seen two of these types of studies
and neither of them were in my mind
particularly useful.
Very annoying, I will say, to figure
this out, but
Uh
Yeah.
Well, I mean, this was a pretty obvious
don't invest in uh
programming language by company.
I mean, it was not a good programming
language in the first place.
It was like this weird Rust and Python
[ __ ]
Why is that [ __ ]
If you new around here, I'm not a fan of
Rust.
I [ __ ] hate that language.
It introduces a huge amount of
complexity and forces a specific
programming model in order to avoid a
class of bugs that like does not even
exist for the most part in very very
large
um
large bases of program design.
Like
memory bugs just aren't that big of a
deal for a lot of different
applications.
No, I really I like the way that C does
it where you just have
you have like a compile this into a slow
binary with a bunch of checks or compile
it into a fast binary without a bunch of
checks.
It's perfect. That's all you need.
Like the complaints I have in C are
I like there C is not a perfect
language. There are a few small things
here and there, but then like
everybody that tries to fix the problems
with C goes away overboard and end up
creating some mod like so-called modern
monstrosity.
>> Okay.
I've gotten till 4:45 today to stream.
C minus.
They should have just called C plus plus
C minus minus.
It's annoying because C is just like C
is an awesome language and then C plus
plus is such an awful language.
Can we add a max time
per end for a max time per experiment?
>> Python C CUDA percentage split
in Puffer.
Um
You can ignore this cuz this is torch.
This is also experimental crap.
This is also like these two are also to
support torch. So we have
I believe it's like
less than 2K lines of Python and 5 or 6K
lines of CUDA C
for the training.
Training it's like a mix of CUDA and C.
We don't have C files and CUDA files.
Everything is just in CUDA files
uh you end up writing much more succinct
code if you do it that way.
And then like some ungodly number of
lines of C code for all the
environments.
But those are those grow horizontal.
Like you do not increase the vertical
like you don't increase the complexity
of the stack adding more M's at all.
Yeah, the CUDA GP stuff will be I mean
basically the goal is by Puffer 6 the
amount of Python required will be zero.
980 and 7.5
Yeah, because it's counting the ends. So
obviously with the ends um
but it's also it's counting like tests
for Python as well which are throwaway
garbage scripts that nobody cares about.
Um
I I think it's like actually 5 6K lines
of CUDA C for the training and then like
sub 2K lines of Python.
That would be very nice.
I read the blog post for the
motivations.
Like I understand that we're ignoring
the entire math behind acquisition
function. Like I understand that we're
ignoring all of that, but like
you have to actually be able to get me a
reasonable estimate of variance if
you're going to write something that
makes use of the variance, right?
That was kind of the key finding with
protein is that carbs was depending very
heavily on having an accurate variance
estimate in the Gaussian process and the
variance estimates were basically
garbage.
That's not much code. Yeah, we've worked
really, really hard to get it down to
what it is.
Um
That's kind of the whole point, right?
Like
5K lines of CUDA C replaces 3.3 million
lines of torch and it's five times
faster.
And that's five times faster than the
optimized torch from puffer three. It's
like many thousand times faster than
anybody else's torch that's not
puffer's.
Well, I mean, the Gaussian processes are
perfectly reasonable.
It's just you don't trust the variance
estimate.
If you have anything else that will work
instead of a Gaussian process just as
well, like by all means. I mean, you
have a very easy way to test this as
well, right? Like, you can go put a You
can go put like a 10 to 15 second cap on
the experiments for breakout because we
know that breakout can be solved in 3
seconds. So, like 5x, give it a
15-second cap.
Get an eight GPU machine, and then you
can run like a 200 experiment breakout
sweep, right?
It's very easy to test the sweep
infrastructure.
Just be careful that you also test it on
other ends once you think you have
something so you don't overfit one end.
Like one end of sweep.
Those approximations.
Yep.
Yeah, I don't much care for uh fancy
math that doesn't work.
I tolerate fancy math that does work.
>> I don't know. I started off thinking
that I would need a ton of math for ML.
And then like I started taking courses
on ML.
And they taught me a bunch of math and
it was really [ __ ] hard. And it was
completely bloody useless. It didn't
work on any real problems. And I started
learning more engineering and I started
being able to solve problems. And like
it felt like I could solve very hard
problems if I just knew more
engineering. I spent more time learning
engineering.
And that's how it went.
And even today it's it's very very rare
that I see um
you know
I see like a very math heavy
breakthrough.
You often see breakthroughs that are
entirely empirical and then have math
retrofit to them.
I think the only thing I've seen lately
that was
um you know very mathy and genuinely
very good is Mu Lan.
>> Uh I tried. Aurora didn't do anything
for us. Arch.
I tried that. It didn't really help.
Pretty much Fred.
Like almost always.
The vast vast majority of failures that
I see in um
in like published research,
it's not they got the math wrong. It's
almost always they completely and
utterly failed to program anything.
No, not even with speed arch.
Oh, I did grab I think I did get the
Polar Express thing,
but not the broader method.
I don't know if the Polar Express thing
was Aurora though. I thought I thought
that was some other that was originally
from something else.
Yeah, let's kill let's kill this.
Come on.
Hey.
I think I figured out what's happening
here.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Uh
this we can do like this.
And okay. So, we should hopefully be
getting
some data here.
So, the idea is if we can just run a
sweep
if we can run a sweep versus the um
First of all, we should get some
policies that at least do okay on the
held out eval.
And then, specifically, we should be
able to train
uh a final policy
against all the previous ones.
I'm hoping we can do something like
that.
That seems decent to me.
This is a quick sweep as well.
Like this population-based training
thing is
Yeah.
Cuz without the self-play, okay. Yeah.
I think I have I think it's roughly
correct.
Okay.
I think
this is good.
Right, we get bot perf.
And then it will just it'll sweep for
this.
And now I suppose we'll just see whether
this finds anything better, huh?
And then we just run uh
we run like a big Elo calc type thing.
And anything that's not significantly
better than random just gets ditched.
And then we'll train against that.
That seems reasonable to me.
>> All right.
I think
How long are we going to let this run
for? They're pretty quick runs. We're
getting eight back a minute.
I'm using a restroom real quick.
I'm going to come back.
And uh I suppose we will see
We will see from there. I guess
The one thing that does bother me a
little bit here
is the number of just crappy runs that
we have.
We'll think about that in a bit. I'll be
right back.
We'll think about that next.
Here's my best guess.
It's probably like some sort of
constrained hyper pram search, right?
And I think that you're probably at some
sort of constrained hyper search. Let's
go look.
They have No, they don't have. I want to
see what they exactly what parameters
they tuned with PBT.
You probably just would like fix some
basic parameters, maybe.
Okay, at the very least this is a
different set of parameters from the
defaults.
But,
are we actually finding like better
perams over time.
I was hoping that we would have within
100 experiments, we'd have something
reasonable.
Oh.
There, we just got a new one.
15% much better. So, we'll give it like
uh we'll give it a some more
experiments. And I think what we'll do
is we'll run Elo across all of these.
Now, we just run uh
a bunch of games across all these.
Oh, also, yeah, we're going to take
we'll take the best one of these and
scale it up as well.
That would be nice.
>> Yeah.
Ah, hang on. This num threads thing is
annoying.
Okay, well actually that that actually
does clear one thing up.
Okay, I actually I messed something up
with this threads thing, but that's
fine.
I think this has a reasonable shot of
working.
I guess I wonder if the policies will be
strong enough.
It just depends on the strategic
diversity, I suppose.
And almost never reach vertically good.
Uh, it's not just like a 01 reward crit.
It's you get a reward for make for
making the top part of the pole go up.
They were using I yeah, when Yasin was
doing that he was using a dumb reward
function, so I just gave him a better
one. I was like, here try this and
that's what everybody's been using as
far as I know.
Like reward engineering is massively
overstated. You really don't need to do
very much of it, but you need to at
least not be completely dumb with it.
I this is at least interesting, I think.
This should be interesting.
>> We'd give this thing more threads and
like maybe a 5-minute budget instead of
a 1-minute budget, but
I think this is basically what you need.
Small velocities. Yeah, but it'll figure
that out, man. You don't need to You
don't need to mess with that.
>> Okay.
Mess with this.
I think it's just going to be run big
tournament, see how Elo is.
Proceed accordingly.
Wouldn't the super fast ends be
interesting for Evo algorithms?
Yeah, in fact, I would say that's the
only way that Evo would make sense at
all.
Um even with stuff being super fast,
I still don't think that that line of
work is in general super promising.
It's cool,
but uh
unless you find some way to do it that
isn't multiple data multiple
instruction.
Like having to have a whole bunch of
different neural nets
is just not that's not how GPUs work.
Basically doing everything on batch size
one.
I don't know if there's Is there a way
you could make hardware that like makes
sense for that?
Like in theory, could you just make
Could you make hardware that just has a
ton of
um
a ton of like batch size one optimized
units where you just keep a whole bunch
of different sets of weights on it.
I don't think so, but I really don't
know enough about hardware design.
To be fair, I think that was um that is
actually the level of thing that you
would need to know in order to
like flip all of modern AI on its head.
You'd basically have to come up with
some architecture that or some algorithm
that nobody else has bothered with
because it's incredibly inefficient on
GPUs, but you know that you can make a
chip for it that would be very, very
efficient because you know about
hardware design and nobody else in AI
does.
And uh
you'd like prototype the thing slow and
get the
flop or whatever like computer equated
result showing that your new method is
good and then you'd go run like do your
own chips for it.
That's how you'd have to do it. That's
like the level of thing it would take to
uh
flip modern AI on its head.
Like you'll see how something like that
is not completely stupid, right?
If you just go deeper like if you just
absorb more of the stack essentially,
the more of the stack you take into
consideration with a design,
um
the more likely it is that nobody is
going to have thought of that whatsoever
before
or like nobody is going to at least have
like no thought of it and then also put
in the effort to go try it.
It's actually pretty rare that you can
just like change one small portion of
the stack and have a massive
contribution to anything.
But like the more things that you're
willing to touch and redo, the more
likely it is that um
you actually come up with something that
is groundbreaking.
I use PufferLib for WTA multi-agent
results. It's really good. What
What is WTA?
I'm glad PufferLib is working for you,
though.
Yeah, we're letting this thing do
whatever garbage.
Weapon target assignment.
All right, cool.
Entire country defense.
Oh, puffer lip now defender of nations.
That's cool.
We're working on multi-agent right here.
This is
I mean, this is essentially a
programming game, but it's like this
tank battle environment.
And we're using this to figure out
self-play.
Okay, we have plenty of uh checkpoints
now, right?
Oh, maybe if I show up uh
if I'm ever in the area
somebody will treat me to some Turkish
coffee then.
Eating with TP I don't know if quantum
is anything, to be honest.
And uh TPUs no, TPUs are just like
those are designed for the current
architectures. Those are basically just
competitors to um
I think TPUs are basically just
competitors to uh
Nvidia GPUs.
Okay.
That's enough experiments.
Hopefully this does no um crash us and
be shitty.
I do wonder if 500
rounds will be remotely near enough.
Probably not.
Uh I played the demo, but I only played
it for one evening. It seemed fun.
I had fun with it. I don't really play
puzzle games that often,
but I'm sure when the full game comes
out will be something I'm in the mood to
play at some point.
I don't know. I was I was expecting it
not to just be like Sokoban though. I
was expecting it to be
rather different.
So, I think it's not all just Sokoban,
is it? I don't know.
When I heard it was like, "Oh, it's
going to be a thousand puzzles." I was
thinking like, "Yeah, it's actually a
thousand different puzzles, you know?"
Oh, very possible, Arch. With something
like that, yeah, very, very possible to
do that.
Like one one quarter of the world. Okay.
So, if it is actually like four separate
different like things with sub ki- I
that's cool.
Four types of puzzles with building
mechanics like
maybe not and I we'll see.
We will see.
I was having fun with it which is funny
cuz I normally I [ __ ] hate puzzles.
>> [laughter]
>> I am I'm kind of a philistine.
To be honest with you. Like
I play RuneScape, okay?
That's what I [ __ ] do.
Are these games actually good?
I had fun with it for the few hours I
played with it.
You didn't need to make a new language
for it but like am I happy to see people
doing [ __ ] and like not god awful unity
or unreal and like actually caring about
performant code? Yeah, that seems cool
and like does it seem like a reasonably
good game as well and obviously
performant and such? Yeah.
Um
It is kind of a meme to make a whole
language and then ship a demo that like
doesn't even [ __ ] have Linux support.
That was kind of weird to me.
But okay.
The language like looked okay. There
were a couple things that got me sort of
thinking, okay, that's interesting.
Um
I think overall it was too much like
you like
way way way far of a departure from your
typical low level that just supports
things that aren't really needed.
Um but there were you know there were a
few cool things.
Low latency, C++
Wait, I just I don't Why C++? Why not
just C?
I C++ is a very shitty bloated language.
Save 20% lines of code.
No, usually so maybe with small
projects, but with big projects the C
ends up being shorter.
It's just people lose track of [ __ ] in
C++ and they end up bloating it with
abstractions, and that's how you really
blow up code bases.
That's how you really blow up code bases
is by just losing track of what the hell
you're doing.
Like the reason that projects are
massive, it's not because like this
string operation was three lines instead
of one, right? It's because you're doing
these million things that don't even
need to be done if you re-architect the
program like this, which you couldn't
see because you have these other million
things going on that also don't matter.
Oh, this is an interesting yellow
spread. We'll see how this experiment
works.
I think this is going to be the main
thing that I run for today.
So,
hopefully we get something out of it. If
not, I don't really know.
Um
yeah, large number of people doing a
thing and large number of people that
make money doing a thing is not at all a
good indicator that said thing is smart.
You learn that very, very quickly if you
interact with any of the big companies.
Like I don't think that there is a
single big company in the world where
the average employee is smart.
Like even the average employee in a
technical role that is supposed to be
smart is smart. I don't think there's a
single company in the world where that
is true.
Small companies, yeah. Startups, yeah.
Big companies, nah.
You don't scale and keep talent density
ever.
self-play rise for this run. So,
hear me out on this, Ryan. So,
um what we did is we have
a sweep
where every experiment in the sweep is
just basic historical self-play.
All right? And then, uh the sweep is
evaluated, like each experiment is
evaluated
against a scripted bot.
Uh so, the sweep is trying to optimize
perf against the scripted bot.
And then, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try to train a I'm going to do
a bigger run
where I use all of these different
checkpoints as the opponents.
And I'm going to see if that gives us
the robustness or not.
So, we just do a big sweep.
We Elo rate all of these things. We keep
all the ones that don't suck.
And then we try to train against them.
Isn't that like training a bunch of
exploiters?
Nope. None of them are training against
the scripted bot. They're all training
against themselves.
So, it's a bunch of different self-play
runs with different hyper-parameters.
So, the only thing that has to be true
here for this to work is that
like hopefully if you do a sweep, you
learn different strategies.
Yeah, exactly, Ryan.
Train self-play validated against the
scripted bot.
This is basically just the coolest thing
ever.
I don't know. I'm pretty bored, frankly.
Like this whole sort of thing is kind of
boring and this hints that there's
I sort of have to just guess here
because
there really isn't any literature I can
rely on for this stuff.
Um
I'm kind of just trying a bunch of
things that seem kind of reasonable and
if none of them work, we're just going
to end up having to go back to a
standard historical self-play
uh and trying to like DR our way to
victory.
Ryan, do you remember the hyperparameter
paper, like the hyperparameter diversity
paper?
I'm kind of hoping there was something
to that at least, even if only a little
bit.
Like the different hyperparameters
learning different strategies thing.
I thought you were on that paper, maybe
not.
My apologies if this is like asking you
like, "Hey, do you remember Vietnam?"
>> Man, wasn't that a fun time when
Americans made like a $20 submachine
gun?
Yeah, I think that's what it I think
that's what it was, Ryan.
I mean Ryan, in my mind like we
basically have nothing to go off of here
because
the DeepMind papers are super bloated
and cost about a trillion
a trillion dollars in compute
and their methods are never super
trustworthy anyways.
Um
the OpenAI ones just use the simple
methods that don't seem like they work.
So, they probably just engineered their
specific problems into working.
And
all the other papers on this topic are
crap.
I don't really know what the hell else
to do.
Oh, I have I have an idea. Let's just go
ruin Yassien's life real quick.
One second.
Where is this damn thing?
What the heck?
Is this literally from these are the
last 2 days?
>> All right, cool. Yasin's been his life
over.
>> Try to make this Daphne's paper makes me
a little more confident.
A self play.
Wait, her paper was um was human data,
right?
>> AI will implement Dota efficiently. No
[ __ ] way.
Nah.
Mhm.
Dota's is Dota they seem to have added
too many new mech.
Well, I mean, so does League. Like they
have to do something every so often. Cuz
it's like the Dota players just play
Dota. They don't play anything else. So
they need something every so often.
See any material worth reading in RL for
low signal on void signal very low
signal noise like trading?
Um
not domain specific to that. I have a
good general RL reading list on my X.
Uh, I see.
Okay, mix.
But everything is better than random, it
says so far. That's interesting.
Okay, well these take forever. I think
we would just try it versus random then.
That'll be quicker.
Entire strategy space with one new
mechanic.
Uh, you don't really
you shift the meta for sure.
This is my
the original was my advisors.
>> [laughter]
>> That's my name.
I don't know. I personally not financial
advice. I thought that um
uh, like the XAI portion was massively
overvalued, but SpaceX was undervalued.
What environment am I working on right
now? This is Robocode. If you look it
up, it is a uh, like 20-year-old
originally in Java, now ported to super
high perf C
like tank battling game.
It was meant to be like uh, you script a
bot and then you like fight other
people's scripted bots.
But it's strategically it's kind of
interesting. It's a really good
self-play game for RL research.
And I'm using it to try to figure out
how we come up with like a good stable
self-play routine
for PufferLib.
Also, for anybody new around here, star
Puffer on GitHub if you haven't already.
What are you doing? It's free. Feed the
puffer a star.
What do we actually add? I know we hit
6K finally.
Which is so cool to have that.
Ban AI in
programming competition is reasonable.
I have no idea who this is.
That was a random uh
All is me apparently. I have no idea who
this is though.
Saiho is former um
Open AI on Dota.
He's really cool.
Highest MMR rank Dota. Like unranked, my
guy. I played it for
I played it for a week before the OpenAI
5 finals just to get some sense of the
game.
I'm like hard stuck iron on League if I
ever do play that. Though realistically,
I'd probably land back in bronze if I
actually played it consistently for a
few weeks.
I am not good at many games.
The only games I've ever been top 1% in
are MMOs.
I mean, they kind of haven't been doing
stuff for a while.
Um I actually if I had to pick like
the single AI company that I care about
the most nowadays is DeepMind.
DeepMind is still cool.
Which is sad, you know, man, because
back in
peak OpenAI days, OpenAI was way better
than DeepMind.
Like when they were doing Dota and
stuff.
The DeepMind guys are just too mathy.
They can't resist the urge to like
overcomplicate the crap out of the
algorithm no matter what they do.
And um it really makes it difficult to
see
what pieces of their discoveries were
necessary versus what pieces of their
discoveries were just them nerding out.
OpenAI was a lot better at that.
But now they don't do anything anymore,
so.
And most of the good stuff was DeepMind.
And to their credit, DeepMind still does
lots of good stuff.
And there's spin-offs as well, like
Isomorphic. It's apparently doing good
stuff.
David Silver, so I have no idea what
he's doing.
If you wouldn't mind solving a couple of
these annoying RL problems, that would
be nice.
Maybe I'd have more spare time then.
Access to EVE Online.
Man, I don't know like
I think that that's mostly [ __ ]
Like they're going to come up with some
crazy-looking thing, I'm sure, with LLM
agents, but it's way less impressive
than uh
things previously done without them.
CCP.
Well, that's just EVE that's just a
game, right? Whoever the hell owns
um
I don't know. I actually I remember I
said like almost a decade ago that the
next obvious environment for RL was an
MMO.
And I started building one and just like
for whatever reason
no nobody caught on to that.
And um
well, now years later we've kind of
shown
many, many discoveries came from that
line of work, but
they still sort of didn't catch on. And
now they're just doing AI LM crap.
Yeah, I don't think there's anything
shady about that though. I think that's
just like whoever the hell happens to
own the the game, right?
Hopefully we can finish up the
experiments for today soon.
I think I have pretty good idea of what
to do here.
>> It's a little bit annoying. It seems
like we have some good policies from
here, but um
not too too many.
I guess what we take anything with like
75%
win rate versus random.
Uh you should be able to get 90 plus so
easily versus random now.
I guess we'll just count.
Yeah, the number of both.
So, it does seem like
they're either really bad or like 90
plus anyway, so probably we can just use
90.
There are not that many policies that
are like 70% that I see.
Are RL insights to come from Puffer RL
even translatable?
LLM RL
Maybe, maybe not. I don't particularly
care and I haven't really thought about
it.
RL is valuable
um very much so independently of LLMs.
I like the 3D Puffer.
Ooh, Puffer.
We love our Puffer. He's our mascot.
We do have um a like touched up version
of him as well.
By uh we got an artist to like fix up a
few things with the model.
I have to I have to like mess with the
lighting though.
Um so I haven't like
it'll probably be part of our like next
update or something when we
get the new puffer in. But he looks
basically the same as the old one. Like
we're not getting rid of this one.
We like our fish.
It's just stuff like the fins not
connecting to the body and stuff.
Puffer's a toxic. Yeah, fugu in Japan. I
don't know why on earth you would eat a
puffer fish.
Like they're so friendly and they're not
tasty and they're the second most
poisonous thing known to man. So why the
hell would you eat that?
Like leave the puffers alone.
You know?
Nobody goes around trying to eat golden
dart frogs, right?
I think blobfish just look gross. I
don't think those are poisonous, are
they?
And I don't even think that they look
gross. I think they look gross like out
of water.
Do full RL approach. Oh yeah, yeah, I
saw that. I don't know what full RL
approach means though. Like
I sort of just assume that most
companies are going to do nothing until
proven otherwise.
Even when they're started by good
people.
>> Unless they're unfunded, in which case
then yeah, they probably produce stuff.
Hopefully we get like what, 10 to 20,
maybe 30 that we can use.
I mean, this is a stupid script. We
could easily If this is the right
approach, we can very, very easily speed
this up.
>> Uh, hey Jess. We are
realizing that we can't run a massive
Elo tournament over all these
checkpoints.
And it's much more practical to just
filter out ones that don't
uh, beat random policies.
We can just filter out essentially all
the failed runs easily enough.
paper with Sutton
That'd be cool.
So with the funding, yeah, this is the
problem Tinkers. I mean, he might be a
big enough name to just like
>> Yeah, you'll see that there are a lot of
startups though that originally started
doing something cool and then they just
ended up doing the bog standard thing.
There are a ton of companies doing that
that is the bog standard thing. Welcome.
Uh
We need some Hypers, don't we?
What on Earth is that question?
How much slower do you think this will
be on single GPU?
It's like eight It's pretty much linear,
Jess.
And I got to go in a minute as well.
But I think we've basically set the
stage for this.
then we go back to [ __ ] around with
this Oracle self-play and we've run a
bigger sweep, I guess.
I mean, I'd say the proper community as
a whole at the very least.
I think like puffer plus open source
with a few people.
Yeah, I think RL will be set within the
year.
Not the calendar year, like within 1
year of now.
Should be a little less.
Depending on um
how much we get distracted by business.
Oops.
And I need eight threads.
>> Business versus research time split?
So, it depends. Like right now, for
instance, I would be doing different
research except that this is needed for
some client work. So, I'd be doing 40
instead of doing I mean I'd be doing 50
instead of doing this like other
self-play feature.
Um so, if you count like
if you count work that has been
prioritized for companies,
it's probably like 40% of my time.
But if you count work that's just
directly for companies, it's like 20% of
my time.
Uh maybe just to be determined.
No free papers up for grabs.
Academia is a bit [ __ ] There's no
incentive.
There are plenty of free papers up for
grabs, man. If you just want to like do
a thing but with Puffer, it's just that
I don't particularly care to do that
anymore.
Like I have better stuff to do.
I'm done publishing. Like
I've I've wasted enough of my life
fighting reviewers and going through
stupid procedures for no reason.
I'm still going to write stuff, but I'll
write like blogs. I'll write, you know,
informative articles. I'll like write I
publish analyses. I mean, I have lots of
articles on my X about our research.
Well, there are some people using Puffer
for stuff.
We have like Google and small Puffer
lab.
16.
I don't know which one people are
citing.
Yeah, we have collabs with um
with Eugene.
Like we have um Puffer drive is the new
driving sim and all, right?
I'm with Puffer.
Yeah.
Puffer 4 is very nice already. Like you
don't even need 5 to do stuff, honestly.
Okay, so
versus bot goes down. I believe this is
a correct eval.
It's annoying doing like in academic
stuff. You never have time to do proper
engineering, but then the reason you
never have time to do proper engineering
is because you haven't done proper
engineering.
>> They can kind of just make [ __ ] up and
they're like, "Yeah, fancy number.
Doesn't replicate whatsoever, but
yeah, sure. We saw this number at one
point during some of our experiments."
Um
Yeah, gaming laptops mostly [ __ ]
suck. I'm going to be honest. I always
insist on having one cuz I want a local
GPU and it always [ __ ] sucks.
They just die after a few years even
with light use.
The cooling on them is just so ass.
Honestly, that thing like the Steam
Machine that like this actually seems
completely reasonable to me.
For this form factor, like
this is completely reasonable.
Okay.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
I've got to go I got to get dinner and I
got to get there.
Um
We're pretty close to having this thing
set up.
I've no idea whether this will work or
not.
We're basically just seeing whether
training with a bunch of policies
from self-play on different hypers
actually helps us on held out eval a
lot.
Um
if not, I guess we'll just come back
tomorrow with more
domain randomization and stuff trying to
just see
okay, if we have to do end specific work
for self-play,
what's the minimum we can get away with?
So, we'll see how that goes.
Um
I'll see if I can get some sweeps
overnight.
For everybody who's new around here,
though, please start Puffer on GitHub,
puffer.ai. The GitHub is right here.
Uh join Discord if you want to get
involved. Follow me on X for more RL
content.